En este video vamos a hablar sobre cómo
multiplicar y dividir números por 10, 100 o
1000. Andrea y Valentina fueron a la feria local,
y Valentina compró 10 collares. Andrea quiere
saber cuánto pagó Valentina por los 10 collares,
sabiendo que cada collar cuesta 15 pesos.
Para encontrar la respuesta, Andrea tiene que
multiplicar el precio de cada collar por todos los
collares que Valentina compró. Para multiplicar un
número natural por 10 solamente agregamos un 0 a
la derecha del número que estamos multiplicando;
el 0 que agregamos corresponde al que está en el
10. Ahora imaginemos que Andrea compró 100 dulces
en la feria y cada dulce costó 2 pesos, ¿cuánto
gastó en total? Vamos a escribirlo: 2 pesos cuesta
cada dulce y compró 100 dulces. Para multiplicar
un número natural por 100 agregamos dos ceros a la
derecha del número que estamos multiplicando; los
ceros que agregamos corresponden a los que están
en el 100. Te habrás dado cuenta de que los ceros
los escribí en otro color, y esto lo hice para que
veas que podemos encontrar un patrón y hacer más
rápido las multiplicaciones por 10, por 100, por
1000 o por cualquier múltiplo de 10. Si te fijas,
cada vez que multipliqué por 10 agregué un cero a
la derecha del número, cuando multipliqué por 100
agregué dos ceros a la derecha del número, así que
el patrón es que, cuando multiplicamos un número
natural por un múltiplo de 10, sólo agregamos a
la derecha el número de ceros por los que estamos
multiplicando. Por ejemplo, digamos que queremos
multiplicar 8 por 1000. Pausa el video y trata
de resolverlo por tu cuenta. Con este patrón sólo
tenemos que agregar tres ceros a la derecha del 8.
Vamos a hacerlo. Así que ya que has aprendido este
patrón, podrás multiplicar rápidamente por 10,
100, 1000, 10 000, 1 000 000 etcétera. Otra forma
de pensar en esto es que el 4 que está en las
unidades va a cambiar de valor posicional por cada
múltiplo de 10 que estemos multiplicando, y las
posiciones que agregamos las vamos a rellenar con
ceros. En este caso, el 4 se mueve de la posición
de las unidades a la posición de las decenas, y
ponemos un 0 en la posición de las unidades. Y
ahora veamos qué pasa con la división de un número
entre 10, 100 o 1000. Digamos que queremos dividir
328 entre 10. Si al multiplicar por 10 agregábamos
un cero a la derecha del número, ahora, al dividir
entre 10, vamos a mover las posiciones de los
dígitos de este número un lugar a la izquierda.
Aquí está el punto decimal en este número. No
lo habíamos escrito porque no lo necesitábamos,
pero ahora sí es necesario, así que para dividir
un número entre 10, 100, 1000 se desplaza el punto
decimal hacia la izquierda tantos lugares
como ceros haya en la cantidad que divide.
El 10 tiene un 0, recorres una posición a la
izquierda; el 100 tiene dos ceros, recorres
dos posiciones a la izquierda, y si dividimos
entre 1000 vamos a recorrer el punto decimal tres
lugares a la [izquierda]. Por ejemplo, si queremos
dividir 275.3 entre 10, entre 100 y entre 1000,
vamos a hacer cada uno por separado. Solamente
tenemos que mover el punto decimal a la izquierda
tantos lugares como ceros tengamos. Al dividir
entre 10, lo movemos un lugar a la izquierda y
nos queda 27.53; al dividir entre 100, lo movemos
dos lugares a la izquierda y nos queda 2.753,
y al dividir entre 1000, lo movemos tres lugares a
la izquierda y nos queda 0.2753. Como puedes ver,
para la división entre 10, 100, o 1000 o cualquier
múltiplo de 10, el patrón es mover el punto
decimal hacia la izquierda la misma cantidad de
ceros que tenga el múltiplo de 10. Y como repaso
del patrón de la multiplicación por 10,
100, o 1000 o cualquier unidad seguida de ceros,
agregamos a la derecha el mismo número de ceros
o, lo que es lo mismo, el punto decimal se mueve
a la derecha la misma cantidad de ceros por los
que estamos multiplicando. Y con esto terminamos.